on va parler de la campagne
présidentielle on a seize jours
maintenant du premier tour de cette
élection et on vous laisse maintenant se
poser une question emmanuel macron
peut-il perdre on va regarder les
derniers sondage d'ipsos on a fait une
courbe où on voit les moments marquants
pour emmanuel macron la guerre en
ukraine son entrée en campagne et on
voit que cette courbe elle fluctue elle
est montée quand emmanuel macron quand
la guerre en ukraine a commencé elle
s'est stabilisée à partir du moment où
il a déclaré sa candidature et puis là
on constate une chute dans vos sondages
stéphane est ce que c'est une chute elle
peut encore durer alors faut s'entendre
sur le terme chute c'est une petite
décrue c'est vrai il est monté jusqu'à
31% ce qu'on a vu avant l'invasion
militaire de l'ukraine et était dans les
zones des 24 25 % il s'est retrouvé dans
la zone des 30 31 % et un effet drapeau
on a devient très clairement vu qu'une
partie de l'électorat notamment
l'électorat le plus âgé c'est à dire le
plus le voyagiste quelque part une
certaine façon rejoignez davantage
qu'auparavant le président de la
république sortant
pour répondre à votre question tout peut
arriver dans une campagne électorale
mais a à peine plus de deux semaines du
premier tour sauf accident électoral est
encore qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
accident électoral sera un immense
scandale peut-être mais à part cette
exception là on imagine mal comment
emmanuel macron ne figurerait pas au
second tour je vais pas en train de
parler du résultat du second tour
évidente que dans l'entre-deux-tours y
aura quinze jours et tout peut arriver
évidemment et tout dépendra évidemment
de 2,2 de la personne qui lui sera
opposé dans cette optique là évidemment
dans cette perspective mais aujourd'hui
dans la dent 4 quotidiennes que nous
menons dont la dernière livraison date
de hier après midi il est à 29 5 % c'est
considérable comme rappelé qu' il a il
est arrivé en tête il y a cinq ans au
premier tour avec 24% des voix la
progression elle est importante et il a
plus de dix points d'avance pour
l'instant sur marine le pen qui était en
seconde position c'est assez inédit dans
l'histoire politique récente qu'à quinze
jours des élections on ait de tels
écarts en tout cas dans les sondages
la cristallisation du vote a lieu pas
forcément elle n'est pas définitive
parce qu'il peut se passer plein de
choses notamment encore pour la seconde
place à un certain à marine le pen il ya
aujourd'hui à cinq personnes cinq
candidats qui sont potentiellement
situation donc toujours selon les
enquêtes d'opinion de pouvoir se
qualifier 6 à jean luc mélenchon il ya
eric zémour même s'ils sont un peu plus
à la traîne que les deux principaux
concurrents donc tout peut arriver mais
c'est vrai que quand on regarde dans le
détail comment se structure
les soutiens des manuels macron au delà
de cette avance considérable 10 points
je le répète il ya plein de il ya plein
de d'indicateurs qui sont au vert pour
lui d'abord c'est le candidat qui
récupère le plus de son électorat 10 à
50 il ya trois quarts des gens qui ont
voté pour emmanuel macron il ya cinq ans
qui sont à nouveau convaincu qu'il faut
voter pour lui c'est beaucoup plus que
les marine le pen dit ya cinq ans ou que
les françois fillon il ya cinq ans en
faveur de valérie pécresse par exemple
d'une part et d'autre part il dispose
encore de réserves parce que sa
politique de siphonnage des voix de la
droite républicaine qu'il a commencé il
ya cinq ans avec la nomination d'edouard
philippe à matignon est bien ici elle se
poursuit il noie c'est assez singulier
d'accord en cinq ans il n'aura pas bougé
d'un iota sa stratégie de
cannibalisation des républicains et il
continue encore on le voit bien valérie
pécresse mais une campagne assez
décevante elle est aujourd'hui dans nos
enquêtes aux alentours de 10% là encore
je rappelle françois fillon avait fait
20 % au premier tour donc vous voyez
bien à quel point la la droite
républicaine est abîmée et
en grande partie chez emmanuel macron
dès 2017 en partie mais ça c'est ça a
continué notamment lors des élections
européennes et ce n'est pas terminé
puisque quand on regarde les les
propositions le programme le
préprogramme d'emmanuel macron pour les
cinq ans à venir on voit bien que c'est
à droite toute quand notamment en ce qui
concerne la réforme des retraites les
conditions d'attribution du rsa ses
déclarations sur le statut des
enseignants il continue à marteler
martelé un certain nombre de mesures ou
de programme destiné à envoyer des
messages à l'électorat conservateur mais
qui reste fidèle à pour l'instant en
partie en tout cas valérie pécresse pour
être action persuadé d'aborder un second
tour face à un candidat de la droite
radicale qui est selon lui en tout cas
le pari que son élection serait
réassurer derrière un nom il a réussi
son opa sur la droite il en récolte
aujourd'hui les fruits
on va dans les sondages et peut-être
dans les urnes le 10 avril oui alors moi
je pense d'ailleurs qu'il a réussi vrai
sens depuis très longtemps c'est à dire
qu'en effet bon il royal la conjoncture
l'ia liq à l'ukraine qui fait qu'il a
connu un bon mais finalement quand on
regarde toutes les enquêtes qui ont été
menées depuis plusieurs semaines depuis
plusieurs mois voire parfois même
parfois depuis plusieurs années on voit
que l'ours conteste l'élection
présidentielle
emmanuel macron et sur un socle qui
toujours un socle à ces eaux où il
maintient disons son socle sociaux
électorale de 2017 et il l'a
manifestement il gagne en effet à partir
d'une triangulation de tous les instants
sur sa droite une partie de cet
électorat
j'allais dire conservateur libéral qui
peut se retrouver aujourd'hui dans un
certain nombre de ses propositions et de
son offre alors après si vous voulez moi
je partage qui vient d'être dit c'est à
dire que sur le premier tour je vois mal
aujourd'hui au regard des intentions de
vote tel quel son banc tout cas établi
que emmanuel macron ne pas être second
tour de l'élection présidentielle sauf
est vrai en effet l'accident majeur
après second tour c'est une autre
question parce que quand même on remet
les compteurs à zéro alors c'est vrai
que en l'occurrence on va voir ce qui va
se passer quel sera le candidat qui va
sortir de cette bataille quand même
assez ardues entre les différents
candidats avec un petit avantage
aujourd'hui à marine le pen puisque
quand on regarde notamment cette semaine
tout tout tout études d'opinion
confondues elle a une petite dynamique
qui l'a fait monter quasiment à 19 ou 20
selon les instituts donc elle continue
malgré tout à à creuser l'écart avec ses
principaux concurrents et notamment par
rapport à eric zemmour
reste ensuite l'inconnu mélenchon qui
lui aussi progressent et il en mesure
finalement de rééditer ce qu'il avait
fait en 2000
potentiellement oui mais avait quand
même un facteur limitatif qui est la
présence d'un candidat communiste
monsieur roussel famille roussel qui
vraisemblablement peut-être l'handicap
dans cette dans cette perspective on va
parler de jean luc mélenchon dans
quelques instants mais sur emmanuel
macron vous êtes tous les deux d'accord
pour dire que sauf accident il serait au
au présent au second tour de la
présidentielle est ce que quand même
nationale plus posé cette question
emmanuel macron peut-il perdre c'est sur
la campagne ou plutôt la non campagne
aujourd'hui n'y a pas vraiment de
campagne présidentielle n'y a pas
vraiment de débat emmanuel macron refuse
le débat avec les candidats il est très
occupé par la guerre en ukraine il est
plus président candidat est ce que ça
les français peuvent lui reprocher lui
faire payer dans les yeux il ya un
certain nombre d' enquête qui avait été
réalisé dès avant l'officialisation de
sa campagne on demande aux gens est ce
que selon vous y ferez il doit débattre
avec les autres candidats il doit
rencontrer les autres candidats avant le
premier tour et une grande majorité de
français ne répondait mais bien sûr mais
ça c'était avant le début de la guerre
en ukraine d'une part et d'autre part
c'était un jugement assez sévère à son
égard lui reprochant de vouloir éluder
la campagne à un jugement qui était émis
par les gens qui de toute façon ne lui
sont pas favorables
donc ce n'est pas vraiment un problème
si vous voulez certes il ya une majorité
de français qui considèrent qu'il
devrait descendre dans l'arène d'être de
de se comporter comme un candidat normal
comme les autres candidats mais ça c'est
ce que pensent les gens de gauche où
c'est ce que je pense les gens de droite
ou d'extrême droite les soutiens
français
d'une campagne classés alors privé enfin
ce son électorat ne considère pas qu'il
se kil que qui les privait d'une
campagne classique bien sûr les autres
peuvent le déplorer mais là encore on
est dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles et ce qui a changé avec
l'invasion militaire de l'ukraine c'est
que la virulence d'une partie des
français à l'égard de la non
participation d'emmanuel macron au débat
politique s'est atténué il ya quand même
des gens qui peuvent même s'ils ne sont
pas favorables à emmanuel macron de même
s'ils ne voteront jamais pour lui
peuvent quand même considérer qu
actuellement est bien compte tenu des
événements il a peut-être autre chose à
faire que d'aller sur les plateaux
télévisés
oui enfin je pense qu'il ya quand même
des zones de fragilité encore qui sont
importants d'abord des traits d'image
concernant emmanuel macron qui sont
quand même des traits d'image
qui relève d'une perception parfois très
négative et extrêmement clivante c'est à
dire qu'en fait lentilles macro nisme
continue à sourdre dans une partie de la
société française et il n'est pas à
l'abri si vous voulez danger et dire une
dynamique de campagne notamment de
second tour d'une sorte de phénomène
agrégatifs qui pourrait
prendre forme à travers finalement tout
sauf macron un tout sauf macro donc ça
c'est potentiellement je vais dire
quelque chose qu'il faut pas totalement
non plus écarté ensuite quand même ce
que l'on voit pas ce que ça va très vite
aujourd'hui et je parle sous contrôle
d'un spécialiste de l'opinion mais c'est
vrai que c'est très volatile quand même
d'une certaine manière et on voit déjà
cette semaine que ce qui a constitué les
faits drapeau c'est à dire le fait que
la nation en tout cas une grande partie
de l'opinion publique se retrouvent du
fait de la guerre en ukraine autour du
chef de l'état qui incarne la nation on
voit que déjà c'est quand même ça
commence à s'infléchir progressivement
selon toutes les enquêtes là vous
regardez cette semaine il est carrément
baisse il ya des enquêtes où il perd six
points dans les quinze jours qui
viennent de se dérouler donc si vous
voulez l'effet de la guerre qui a été en
effet un effet profondément positif un
moment donné pour les intentions de vote
en ce qui le concerne est quelque chose
qui peut s'amuser et plus on va se
rapprocher quand même il faut être clair
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle plus ça va se polariser
plus l'intérêt sur l'élection on va se
manifester plus les mobilisations vont
se faire donc là en effet il ya une
petite camille zones de risque pour
emmanuel macron et d'ailleurs je crois
que l'on est conscient du côté de
l'entourage du président de la
république et de la république en marche
lorsque l'on dit et ce n'est pas
seulement un effet rhétorique que rien
n'est fait oui vous avez raison de
parler d'une sorte de banalisation de la
guerre en ukraine qui a contribué à
atténuer cet effet drapeau parce que
finalement la guerre dure plus longtemps
que prévu ça fait maintenant un mois et
des gens ne sont plus dans le même effet
de sidération c'est vrai l'autre l'autre
risques qui pèsent sur les manuels
macron c'est une démobilisation de son
électorat au premier tour parce que la
raison et parce que je serai serait fait
et ça c'est quelque chose qui est que la
majorité et que le président ont bien
compris il ya toujours cette possibilité
que les gens se disent mais pourquoi se
déplacer ce jour là je rappelle que
comme le premier tour aura lieu durant
les vacances scolaires au début des
vacances scolaires en tout cas il ya des
gens qui peut se dire je me réserve pour
le second tour parce que le premier tour
de toute façon on est sûr d'y être et
notre candidat est sûr d'y être et ça
c'est un vrai problème pendant les
vacances scolaires d'autant plus qu'on
est quand même dans un contexte depuis
quelques années de forte progression de
l'abstention scrutin après scrutin
sont les traits d'image qui peuvent lui
nuire dans les yeux alors il ya quelque
chose de persistant depuis quasiment le
début de son quinquennat c'est cette
arrogance cette prétendue arrogance
qu'on lui reproche il ya toujours ce
cliché de président des riches dont on
parle moins actuellement dans la
campagne parce que malgré tout la
campagne se déroule du centre-droit à
l'extrême droite aujourd'hui on parle
peu de la gauche c'est pour ça que dans
l'hypothèse d'un second tour pourrait
l'opposer à jean luc mélenchon je pense
que le spectre du candidat des des
riches pourrait ressurgir et lui coûter
cher mais voilà on lui reproche sont
parfois sa prétendue arrogance son
arrogance le fait d'être président des
riches et surtout le fait ça c'est un
autre problème surtout pour un président
qui se se représente d'avoir de disposer
d'un bilan insuffisant alors certes les
français reconnaissent qu'il ya un
certain nombre de crises et les trois
crises les gilet jaune il ya eu il ya eu
la copie de l'ukraine que c'est pas tout
n'est pas de sa faute mais malgré tout
quand on rentre domaine par domaine les
français je parle notamment de la
sécurité ou de la réforme des
institutions comme les français sont
assez sévères à l'égard de ce qui n'a
pas été fait par le président à l'égard
en d'autres termes ce qui est ce que
terry pour un homme politique de
promesses non tenues
[Musique]